so end of day we are going to have a
little diversity policy freshener
because of some more problems at the
scranton branch
and i have a list of business startups i
got from the chamber
yes i am going to need someone to cold
call them oh i can do that
jim's nice enough
i don't i don't know how well he's
fitting in here
he's always looking at the camera like
this
what is that this should have been up
yesterday we are right
what is that
the committee to plan parties invites
you to a margarita karaoke christmas
there's no such thing as the committee
to plan parties there is now we just
started it well you can't just start a
committee you have to have funding
what's your funding two hundred dollars
what's ours again um 201. right
hey a margarita karaoke christmas party
that sounds like fun no that is not a
party there's only one party and it's
hosted by the party planning committee
and it starts at three o'clock then why
are there two flyers oh i understand
that this is confusing for everyone let
me explain
there's a party that starts at three
right and then there's a way more fun
party that starts at 2 45
right and if you're interested in the
way more fun party all the info can be
found here on our more brightly colored
flyer
i didn't see where it was
look how cute he is
and he's trying to shoot with a smoke
grenade i'm sorry what are you
whispering tonight did nothing you just
concentrate on turning around i'm trying
i just
just tap s then d
oh
any last words no what
wow
it's like go bad
you stay here and have fun cause i'm
gonna go out back and shoot hoops with
david wallace okay
oh um don't mention that you and i are
dating cause i think he might still have
feelings for me wallace
what the hell have you dated like every
guy here
wow
okay
you got me i so got you so none of them
of course not
i mean you're kind of like
my first
really
oh my god it's so easy it's not even fun
what's going on with fairfield county
schools karen did you generate that
price list um shoot
uh i will i'm sorry okay just get it
done
jim will you make sure
oh yeah definitely
suck up
josh did you hear what i said thank you
everyone
damn it
what's up
uh nothing they're just out of hers
chips oh but don't worry about it my
snack food doesn't fall under the
umbrella of your authority
um that's where you're wrong
i'm your project supervisor today
and i've just decided that we're not
doing anything
until you get the chips that you require
so i think we should go get some
now please
i grab this
and i turn it on and i say prepare
yourself for the utica chain store
massacre no that's that is incredibly
dangerous no don't worry chain is off no
it's not you know i think i'm just gonna
distill all of this and send it in an
email to my team email's not scary this
is an opportunity don't don't blow it so
whenever you two
uh in about a month
wow
that is wonderful congratulations thank
you that just all happened so fast it's
really amazing congratulations karen
so is there a guy or a
person
or a
sperm
machine that did this to you or
yes michael my husband oh needed me
great
oh my god oh my god karen is back
no i'm not doing that it doesn't have to
mean anything just
do it for stan lee
come on jim just climb on top of her
think about stanley oh god
oh jim
if this is it for me promise me
something
jim host
hey karen
uh what are you doing here first of all
hi
what are you doing here
you good
i'm just checking on the other branches
michael wants me to do that from time to
time so
do not tell karen about the industrial
copier
copy that
i cried for weeks over that guy so yeah
seeing him climb out of a pt cruiser in
a ladies warehouse
uniform felt pretty good
i think i could go for some tuna fish
right about now
oh got my rod here
click click click click click
click click click click click click
click click click click click
i got one get one
hey hey hey
so
tandy is in a rare
form today
yeah he should not encourage him
encourage him
i'm the victim
okay he's fishing for me
we got it decently look i i've got like
15 new clients that i've inherited from
dwight and each file is password
protected with a different mythical
creature so
i'm sorry
i can't
fine party pooper
let me ask you did you accomplish what
you wanted listen lady
you can expect these kind of
repercussions as long as you keep trying
to poach our people i'm taking stanley
then we will burn utica to the ground
granted maybe this was not the best idea
but
at least we care enough about our
employees that we are willing to fight
for them
and if you so much as harm a hair on
stanley's head
we will burn utica to the ground
jim hang on a second yes
so you're still
doing this kind of stuff huh yeah trying
to quit though
if you wanted to see me you could have
just called me like an adult oh no i
didn't want to see you
not that i'm not happy to be seeing you
right now i'm just saying
ultimately i was here for the copier
equal i'd say it was equal
so good to see
i mean it's just that
you know pam and i are still dating so
and i just mean that
things are going really well so i didn't
want to see
you
oh things are going really well
are they they are that's great that's so
great i want to hear more about how
happy you are with pam can you tell me
more about that thank you so much for
coming to utica and breaking my copier
and telling me how well things are going
in your relationship really thank you
all right
you are welcome i'm going to go because
of um
traffic traffic yeah oh def go
go cause a truck definitely
beat the traffic
you